hello hello everybody today we're going
to talk about object detection and
object detection is the computer's
capability to understand images by
putting tight bounding boxes around the
different objects in the image and then
classifying each bounding box to its
correct type in this case an airplane
and this is Joseph and he is one of the
researchers behind the yellow algorithm
it's really one of the most amazing
algorithms today in object detection and
what he showed in a TED Conference last
last April is really impressive he took
a video of the audience and all of the
detections of the dozens of people
including very small objects they were
holding are being done in real-time
using his algorithm with a regular video
camera he is holding in his hand and
Joseph is really with his algorithm
really pushing the boundaries of the
state of the art of object detection
towards algorithms which are more and
more real-time while other researchers
are really pushing the boundaries of the
state of the art towards more and more
accurate algorithms this is what we're
going to talk about today my name is
Eden Basu and I'm the AI team leader at
a dock where for the last year I've been
working on object detection algorithms
for the medical imaging domain and I
really think that for those of you
looking for the next product to work for
to build for your company or for the
next idea to found a start upon object
detection could be a really good
opportunity for you and the reason I'm
excited about this technology is because
it combines a lot of opportunities for
new products in really large markets
together with very high technological
maturity and really significant
improvements
occur on almost a monthly basis and
that's why in the next 40 minutes I'm
going to first give you a short intro
then I'm going to present just a taste
into some of the very interesting
opportunities for using object
detections for new application and then
I'm going to deep dive into the main
part of the talk to give you intuition
for the leading algorithms that are
working today and wrap up with five
guidelines that can help you take your
first steps in the field more
effectively and avoid rookie mistakes
that I made when I started working on it
so these three technologies are actually
the most mature technologies today in
computer vision and they are the engine
behinds the computer's capability to
understand images classification is
actually pretty much the base technology
image classification is taking an image
that contains a single object and then
classifying it to the object class is it
a cat or a dog detection which is the
subject of our talk today is taking an
image that contains many object putting
a bounding box around each object and
classifying each bounding box correctly
this is the classic image for image
classification and but to make computer
vision really useful image
classification straits that image image
classification is really not enough
because because the world is more
complex than that and it's really
important to understand that object
detection is not a futuristic technology
it's already a very mature technology
and we're already seeing it combined at
the core component in many products we
are all using such as Facebook's face
detection and also in rising product
such as self-driving cars where in
Google's case I have already driven more
than 4.5 million kilometres using object
detection as a core component now I want
to give you a small taste before we deep
dive into the algorithms for three of
the really big opportunities for using
object detection imagine
how much more efficient the world of
visual intelligence could be when
computers using object detection will be
able to speed up the work of the huge
amounts of people currently analyzing
these types of images by themselves and
the same thing goes for the world of
healthcare when some when today some of
the most major bottlenecks are exactly
where you an expert and usually a doctor
is required to analyze images in very
high volumes of images by themselves and
detecting very small findings and this
is an example of a detection of the
algorithm that we work on at a doc and
urgent finding in a brain CT scan but
this technology could help in a lot of
other areas in healthcare as well and
the last example is robotics and this
example really blew my mind because in a
series of papers they showed that in
order for a robot to wash your dishes
you will need him to find the grasping
point on the spoon and they showed in
these papers that you can frame the
problem of finding the grasping point on
the spoon as an object detection problem
but this time instead of the object
being defined as the spoon as a whole
the object is is defined as the grasping
point and this is the ground truth that
was used to train these algorithms and
they used some of the living object
detection algorithms almost as is and it
just worked and I really think this
demonstrates the sheer robustness of the
object detection technology because you
don't have to limit yourself to two
additional objects with clear boundaries
and you can really be creative with how
you define your object such as grasping
points so this wraps up the introduction
part and now I want to deep dive into
the algorithms and I think that even for
those of you who have read some of these
these papers how many of those are in
the audience right now by the way okay
great not so many so I really hope that
even for those of you that have read
some of these papers I will be able to
shed a new light about the intuition
behind these algorithms so let's begin
first the only two slides for us
background for those of you without
background in computer vision so you
will be able to follow the rest of my
talk this is a convolutional feature
extractor or in short a feature
extractor and it is the brain behind all
of the different computer vision
algorithms whether its classification
segmentation or detection this is the
brain that lets the computer make sense
of images and it's built layer after
layer the first layer looks for the most
simple features in the image such as
edges lines circles the layers in the
middle of the feature extractor use
these simple features in order to
construct and then look for more cool
features of growing complexity such as
these textures and even wheels and the
features in the last layer use the
features from the middle layers in order
to build the features of the highest
complexity such as faces of dogs and
humans and even this feature which is a
unicycle wheel with a human's foot on
top of it so this is a feature extractor
and when you put inside the feature
extractor and input image what is the
output that you get so the output of the
feature extractor is a set of feature
Maps actually thousands of feature map
one feature map for every feature in the
last layer of the network and these are
just three examples of these features so
you can see that for the feature of the
dog face the feature map that you get is
completely dark because there is no dog
in the input image but for the feature
of the unicycle wheel the entire feature
map is dark except for this region that
is very bright and corresponds to the
area where the unicycle wheel is present
in the input image and this means that
there is high presence of a unicycle
wheel in this this area of the image and
the output of the feature extractor is a
3d concatenation of all of these
thousands of feature Maps into a 3d
feature map so this wraps up
introduction for those of you without
background in computer vision so once we
have the feature extractor and as I said
we have we used this feature extractor
for all tasks in computer vision so this
is an example of classification if you
want to use this feature extractor to
perform a classification task and this
is really amazing all you have to do is
take the feature extractor as easy don't
need to change anything and just plug in
X something we call a classification
head on top of the feature map and what
is the classification head a
classification head is actually a neural
network that takes the feature map as
its input and that's something that is
analogous to logistic regression it it's
the output of this neural network the
size of the output is the number of
classes that we want to classify into
and we use an activation called the
softmax activation in order to to force
these outputs to sum up to one so they
will be able to represent the
probability of classification per class
so this is the classification head but I
told you that we're going to talk about
detection and for detection we need
bounding box coordinates so we need to
regress those bounding box coordinates
and the intuitive way to do it is using
your regression head so what is the
regression head a regression hat is very
very similar idea to classification head
and again we use a neural network which
input is the feature map only this time
the outputs for each bounding box we
have four outputs and this time this
neural network is for those of you with
records in machine learning is analogous
to linear regression instead of logistic
regression and we just use the linear
activation because we don't want to
bound these outputs we want them to
represent coordinates and for each
bounding box we'll get four outputs x
and y in pixels which will present the
coordinates of the center of the
bounding box and W an age also in pixels
which represent the width the predicted
width and height of the bounding box so
this is a very intuitive idea and
actually the naive way to do regression
is just do it just as well as we do
classification just plug in the
regression head to the side of the
classification head on top of the
feature map and this approach it's
pretty amazing but it works it's so
simple and it works but the problem is
that it that just doesn't work that well
so about three or four years ago the top
object detection experts in the world
thought of themselves deep learning
since it has in was introduced into the
task of image image classification has
driven significant improvements in the
classification accuracy in the which is
the main metric of the image
classification task but we weren't able
to see such improvements in the task of
object detection so their intuition was
if only we could reduce and this is
really important to reduce the problem
of object detection into a problem of
image classification then we would be
able to leverage our achievements in
image classification to the problem of
object detection so they wanted to
reduce object detection into image
classification and that's exactly what
they did so they took the input image
and then you they use that traditional
computer vision algorithm in order to
predict thousands of different bounding
boxes on top of the input image find
interesting areas with different
heuristics such as using the edges of
the image and then they saw many of
these these objects were just covering
the background but many of them happen
to fall on the objects that we were
actually interested in detecting but
it's not really practical to output
thousands of bounding boxes from the
algorithm this is the useless algorithm
of course so what they did is then they
cropped each of these thousand bounding
boxes and these are just three examples
of cropped bounding boxes they cropped
them one by one and now you can see that
this image any image classification
algorithm will have a very easy job
classifying it as background and this
image any image classification algorithm
will have a very easy job classifying it
as a car so actually they they were
successful in reducing object detection
into image classification because now
once we know that this bounding box
represents a car and this is a very easy
task because of our accuracy in image
classification we don't need to regress
the bounding box coordinates we already
have the bounding box coordinates that's
how we crop this image so this approach
actually worked very well and this is
the full flow of the algorithm you take
the input image and then you predict
with the traditional computer vision
algorithm thousands of bounding box all
over the image in parallel you put the
input image into into a feature
extractor and get the feature map then
you crop each of these proposals
bounding boxes you crop it one by one
from the feature map these are for
example of cropped feature map out of
the thousands of degree are cropping and
then sequentially you input each of
these cropped feature maps into a
classification head which is a neural
network so you run this neural network
thousands of times for each of the
proposals and classify it and then they
show that now if you plug in the
regression head in addition to the
classification head it even further
improves the performance of this
algorithm because now the task of the
regression head is not to regress the
bounding box coordinates from scratch we
already have bounding box coordinates
the task of the regression head is only
to take the existing bounding box
coordinates and refine them and that
that apparently is a much easier task so
the main idea and what okay first of all
just to make sure you understood all the
little details previously I showed you
the classification head on top of the
entire feature map and now we put only a
cropped feature map into the
classification head which means the
input to the neural network is the
cropped feature map but apart from that
it's exactly the same idea and same
thing goes for the regression head so to
me the most interesting interesting
thing in this paper
is that and this is this motive is also
a major motive in all modern and leading
object detection algorithms is that if
you are able to focus the neural
networks attention in two different
parts in the image then this enables you
to reduce the object detection problem
into something that is only slightly
more difficult than an image
classification problem and that helps
you solve object detection and actually
these this approach has brought the most
significant improvement that we'll seen
in years in the field of object
detection so this algorithm is called
fast our CNN but don't let the name fool
you because one of its most major
problems would work was that it just
wasn't fast enough
so to demonstrate why it wasn't fast
enough I want to show you another video
from the same TED talk where it
demonstrates an algorithm with a similar
speed and you can see that the bounding
box is accurate but it's always just too
late even though is not working that
fast but even if your application is not
speed sensitive speed is still very
important for your algorithm because the
faster your algorithm the the faster
your research pipeline will be and the
more experiments you will be able to
conduct in a certain period of time and
in an empirical field
like deep learning it's very important
to do as much experiments as you can
because it significantly increases your
chances of success so a fast algorithm
is very important and now I want to show
you how the leading algorithms today
solve the problems of object detection
accuracy and speed with faster
algorithms
[Music]
there are a lot of hyper parameters yes
and but let's talk about it after I
showed more modern algorithms because it
will be more interesting to talk about
it then okay okay so how do we really
solve the problem of detection today in
all the living algorithms and the living
approach is a sliding window approach
you take a sliding window and you put it
on top of the input image and I want to
just demonstrate what if what it means
that it's sliding you just slide it to
different locations around the image and
it's important to understand that once
the sliding window is located in a
certain place in the image it's as if
each sliding window as the corresponding
area in the feature map and it's in a
certain location of the sliding window
it's as if this part of the feature map
is cropped and only this part is fed
into the classification and regression
heads so this means that the
classification and regression heads when
the sliding window is in this location
they are completely unaware that the
rest of the image even exists okay and
this is very important to understand so
let the window slide and you can see
between the window is in the first
location it focuses the attention of the
classification head on to an area which
is clearly background so it has a very
easy job of classifying it as background
and same thing goes for the second
location of the sliding window and for
the third location of the sliding window
you can see the de classification has
attention is focused on the person's
head and this makes it very easy to
classify it as a person and we'll talk
about the regression of the bounding box
coordinates in a minute so I want to
skip a few locations of the sliding
window and the next location I'm showing
you is just located on top of the
unicycle wheel and again because the
attention of the classification that is
focused then it's very easy to classify
it as a unicycle wheel so now let's talk
about regression again we already have
pretty good bounding box coordinates
because the coordinates of the sliding
window are the coordinates for our
pretty good coordinates for the bounding
box around the unicycle wheel so again
the job of the regression head is only
to fine-tune or refine these existing
coordinates instead of regressing them
from scratch but now I want to show you
a more interesting example in the wendel
sliding window is located on above the
person's head actually the bounding box
you want it to predict in many cases is
a bounding box that covers the entire
person's body but because a sliding
window is small we have no location of
the sliding window that is even aware
that there is an entire person's body in
the image so this seems like a real
limitation of the sliding window
approach how can we predict bounding box
coordinates two areas of the image that
we are not aware that they exist as an
intuition as humans we understand that
it's enough for us to look at the head
and shoulders of a person in order to
understand if this person is standing up
or lying down and in which direction so
this gives us information about the
bounding box even if we don't see the
entire body it's also enough to
understand if this person is tall or
short which can give us information
about the height of the bounding box
that we need to predict and I really
believe that the most beautiful
algorithms in deep learning take a prior
belief from the human intuition and find
an elegant way to encode it into the
network architectures and this intuition
is so significant that it this compo the
component that encodes this intuition is
now a part of all living object
detection algorithms and it is called
incur boxes and these anchor boxes
enable us to solve not only this problem
of bounding boxes that are larger from
the sliding window but also many
different problems or that have to do
with predictive Mountain bounding boxes
for objects
multiple scales and shapes so these two
algorithms that I showed you are
actually two examples of the two main
types of object detection algorithms and
these types are the single stage
algorithm and the two stages algorithm
the last algorithm I showed you that
uses the sliding window approach is
actually pretty much gives you the idea
of the leading algorithms in the single
stage and the algorithms with the
proposal I showed you is a previous
generation of the two stages algorithm
and I will show you them leading
algorithm for the two stages approach in
a few minutes so it's important to
understand that these two types of
object detection algorithms single stage
and two stages
actually sit on different sides
typically of maybe the most important
trade-off in orbital detection the speed
accuracy trade-off and the single stage
algorithms are typically much faster but
less accurate than the two stages
algorithm and why are they much faster
it's because the sliding window approach
can be implemented using convolutions
throughout the entire network it's what
we call in deep learning a fully
convolutional network so using only
convolutions that are shared on top of
the entire image is much faster than
what we do in two stages where for each
of the thousands or in modern algorithms
hundreds of proposals on the input image
we need to crop hundreds of or thousands
of different parts of the feature Maps
one after the other and feed them one by
one into a neural network so we need to
run the neural network thousands of
times instead of only once in this case
and this is why this is a much more a
fish computationally efficient and fast
from the drawings it might seem like we
are cropping the sliding window location
but we are not actually cropping
anything we use convolutions to simulate
cropping but because we don't actually
crop we only run the neural network once
and
all the computations are shared for the
entire input image so there is one thing
that is common between these two
algorithms and that these two types of
algorithms and that that is that they
both use attention focusing the neural
networks attention but they use
different mechanism to do it the single
stage algorithm uses the sliding window
is the attention mechanism and the two
stages algorithm uses proposals on the
input image is the attention mechanism
okay so first of all is an intuition to
white the two stages algorithm is also
more accurate there are several
explanations for that one hand wavy
explanation is that because you crop
each bounding box by itself and then you
run each cropped bounding box through a
neural network this neural networks
computes or extracts features that are
much more relevant locally to this
specific bounding box so it enables you
to get much higher accuracy for the
refined coordinates of the bounding box
then by this approach which where all
the convolutions involve features that
are relevant to the entire image so now
I want to present you faster are CNN
which is the evolution of faster CNN and
it is currently probably the most
accurate object detection algorithm and
you can see this is the full flowing of
the algorithm and you can see that it
actually looks exactly like the previous
algorithm that I showed you first our
CNN that's because the main difference
between his algorithm these two
algorithms are not seen in this image
and the main difference is that is in
the module that that gives us the
proposals over the input image and how
does it work in faster CNN we used a
traditional computer vision algorithm to
give us the proposals and this approach
had two problems
first of all this algorithm was
relatively slow by itself and second of
all the accuracy of these proposals was
very low so we had to go over thousands
of proposals with Anu separately with
the neural network and that took a lot
of time so faster are CNN they decided
to replace the traditional computer
vision algorithm with a neural network
that will give us the proposals but not
just any neural network they used the
single stage object detection algorithm
as the proposal mechanism they use the
sliding window algorithm as the first
stage that gives us the proposals so
what it what is going on here is that
you get the input images put it through
a feature extractor get the feature map
and then run the sliding window on top
of the feature map to get this time
hundreds of bounding boxes on top of the
image the sliding window is always the
same size of window yes in more in most
our leading implementation the sliding
window is always the same size but right
so i didn't dive into all of the details
of how you implement anchors you can
have for each sliding window you can
have instead of one regression head you
can have several regression heads each
of them predicting one bounding box and
each of these regression head can
specialize or even though it operates on
a sliding window of the same size if you
have several regression head each
regression head can train during
training only in the objects of
different sizes one regression head
wooden tray will train on large objects
and one regression head will train on
small objects and one regression head
will train on wide objects and because
of the intuition I showed you about an
course a window of a fixed size is
enough if you use anchors correctly okay
so they used the sliding window approach
in order to give us the proposals and
the classification has in this case
doesn't classify into
a thousand classes or a hundred classes
or the number of classes that we have
have it just classifies into two classes
and these are classes that interest us
in this stage is it an object or is it
background so now this I'll this
algorithm is much faster for two reason
first the sliding window approach works
much faster than the previous
traditional computer vision algorithm
and second the the proposals from the
neural network are much more accurate
than the proposals from the previous
algorithm and that's why we now only
have to go typically over between 100
and 300 proposals instead of thousands
that we all had to go in the past and I
reminded that each of these proposals we
need to run in your separate run of a
neural network so this is more than an
order of magnitude of improvement in the
number of neural networks that we need
to run so just to remind you and I close
all the details in your head this is the
full flow of the algorithm and it's
pretty much exactly like faster CNN but
the main idea is using a neural network
which is the single stage object
detection algorithm as the bounding box
proposal algorithm and now to wrap up
the part about the intuition for the
algorithms and to give you like the
common language that is required the
most believing implementations for the
single stage algorithm are called SSD
single-shot detector and Yolo yes I'm
not kidding it's you only look once and
for the two stages algorithm the leading
implementations are faster are CNN we
which are just presented and this
algorithm was the main component in all
winning entries in all object detection
competitions in the last years and RFC n
which is a really beautiful algorithm
but I don't have enough time to talk
about it today but I really recommend
you to read the paper okay so the
the algorithms I showed you are really
the state of the art of object detection
this is how it works and I think it's
surprisingly simple to understand the
intuition and you you asked the question
about is it just a black box or can we
yeah okay
so sorry the
explain again the traditional computer
vision algorithm oh okay so
so actually I don't have a really good
answer for that because I don't deal in
my day-to-day with the traditional
computer vision algorithm that that has
generated the proposals because this is
the previous generation of the
algorithms and no one really uses it for
several years already but for faster our
CNN which uses the single stage
algorithm as the bounding box proposal
algorithm there are a lot of hyper
parameters which you can fine tune in
order to get better proposals for
example I told you that you can go back
to the slide so you can use I told you
can you can put not one regression head
but several regression heads and each of
these regression heads will specialize
on a different size and shape of objects
during training so you can play with the
number of regression heads and with the
what exactly what size and shape each of
them specializes in and this is one
example of how you can really improve
the network's performance for proposals
okay but there are many other hyper
parameters as well so this wraps up the
part about the intuition for the leading
algorithms of object detection and if
there are two points that I would like
you to I recommend you to take from this
part take-home yeah is the first point
is the importance of using an attention
mechanism to focusing the neural
networks attention into different parts
of the image and it's the this idea is
combining two all the leading object
detection algorithms and it enables us
to reduce the object detection problem
into something that is only slightly
more difficult than a classification
problem and that is a very important
there is a that was a that is a very
important concept in object detection
and the second thing is the speed
accuracy trade-off and but I will
calculate more about it in a minute so
my first guideline for those of you that
want to really go in deeper into this
field and start working is that first
it's really important
to be on top of the newest research in
the field of early detection is a very
hot field of research and these eight
examples are eight examples no or
another only eight improvements from the
last year these are these are in my
opinion only the eighth most significant
improvements from the last year in
object detection and I'm just going to
annex an example to talk about one of
them but these are improvements that if
you will be able to implement fast into
your product and algorithm you will gain
significant improvement to your product
so this is actually a paper from about a
month ago and they showed that if you
use a novel loss function with the
single stage algorithm which until today
the single stage algorithm is as I told
you was faster and less accurate so they
showed that if you use a novel loss
function as the with the single stage
algorithm you are able to gain better
accuracy than any two stages algorithm
seen until today and still be faster
than all of the two stages algorithms so
using the loss function this new loss
function you are able to combine the
speed of the single stage detectors with
the accuracy that until today was only
seen in two stages detectors and this is
a really significant improvement and
it's beyond the scope of this talk to
talk about what exactly this loss
function does but it in a general idea
it has to do with dealing with the class
imbalance because there is a very large
with there is very significant class in
balancing of AB in obligate action for
the sliding window most of its locations
are seeing only background and very few
locations are seeing positive samples so
there is very large class imbalance and
this loss function targeted this issue
and was able to gain significant
improvement
the second guideline is that these
algorithms were developed for the domain
of everyday images and most likely if
you will take these algorithms and work
in your companies you will probably try
to adapt them to new domains such like
we do for medical imaging at a dock and
you need to really understand the basic
assumptions behind these algorithms
because they don't necessarily hold for
your domain as an example I showed you
that in order to classify this area as a
unicycle it's enough to see only the
local context but in medical imaging
even a human expert radiologist that
look at this looks at the CT scan in
order to classify and to detect an
urgent finding in the brain usually he
needs to see not only the small area of
that finding he needs to see the entire
image and so and many times even 3d
context of many slices of the CT scan
and this is not incorporate incorporated
by default into the traditional
algorithms and you need to understand
all of these basic assumptions very well
in order to understand how you do your
adaptations well and the third thing is
I really recommend you don't be fooled
by declarations in December of 2016 the
two leading implementations the papers
behind the two leading implementations
for the single stage algorithm both said
that they are outperforming or
comparable to the state-of-the-art
faster are CNN but that was actually not
true and the reason for that is that it
is very easy even in the best papers to
conduct even by mistake misleading
comparisons because there is not a
single faster our CNN faster our CNN is
an algorithm and there are many hyper
parameters that you can play with in
order to increase its accuracy so they
choose they chose one one point and they
show that there they outperform it but
they didn't really outperform
state-of-the-art accuracy of faster our
CNN at that time so in order to deal
with this issue I really recommend you
to follow the cocoa
lead the cocoa challenge leader board
the cocoa challenge is probably the main
and most important challenge in object
detection and this challenge has to do
with accuracy and when I develop
algorithms III want when I choose the
algorithm that I the idea that I want to
incorporate into my algorithm I want to
be sure that they will they will
increase my accuracy and I'm not wasting
my time and when you looked when in
December of 2016 at the cocoa leader
board none of the competitors and
definitely not the leading competitors
were using no neither SSD nor Yolo and I
think this is a very significant thing
to understand and the top five were
using faster are CNN and RFC n which are
the two stages algorithm but focal loss
the new loss functions that I talked
about a few minutes ago have for the
first time enabled a single stage
algorithm to get into the top 5 of the
cocoa leaderboard and now I want to talk
a little bit more about the speed
accuracy trade-off so I already told you
that in order to choose your point of on
the trade-off I need to choose between
single stage and two stages algorithm
but it's not enough even your choice of
the specific implementation will affect
your place on this spectrum and there
are many other hyper parameters that you
can play with in order to choose your
exact location on the spectrum so I
really recommend you to go to this paper
by Google research and they took dozens
if not more of configurations of the
different types of algorithms with
together with different feature
extractors and different hyper
parameters for these algorithms and
compare these dozens of configurations
in terms of speed and accuracy so if you
want to choose
your point wisely I really recommend you
to learn from there very thorough work
and the last point is that if you will
start working today on object detection
I really recommend you to use the tensor
flow object detection API this is in my
opinion probably the easiest way to
build object detection algorithms today
within 10 minutes from when you will
start using it you will already be able
to download a train faster are CNN or
SSD or or any other leading object
detection algorithm and use it with your
own photos and if you want to train it
on your own data set pretty much all you
have to do faster are CNN is already
implemented and pretty much all you have
to do they have an interface for faster
our CNN feature extractor it has only
three abstract method and all you have
to do is implement these three very
simple methods for example just to show
you how simple they are one of the
methods is free process which means how
you want to pre-process your input image
before you put it into the feature
extractor which is basically usually
resizing it or maybe reducing the mean
normalizing it in some way or something
like that
so this is a very simple abstract class
that you need to implement and you were
already able to start training on your
own data so to sum up my talk I have
four short points one is that the object
detection is a very mature technology
and that there are a lot of new
applications that are just waiting for
someone to take them and do something
with them number two and three are a
little bit in their twine and to bring
value from object detection you don't
need to reinvent the obvious objection
detection algorithms they already exist
you need to take them and adapt them
into a new domain and adapting these
algorithms into a new domain is hard by
it's much less it's much more it's much
less hard than but then inventing these
algorithm inventing these algorithms
took years but adapting them to new
domains is much easier because the
search space is much smaller and it's
bounded by the existing algorithms and
your intuitions about your domain and
the last point is that I recommended to
use my guidelines and I i hope they will
they will enable you to start working
much more effectively and avoid working
mistakes that i made when i started
working in the field and the last thing
I want to ask you before I go is which
industry are you going to transform
first thank you very much
do we have time for questions because
other of the talking books
orientation
but it's not necessarily such a
different problem I will just give a few
example actually the state of the art we
didn't have enough time to go to go into
the entire entire complexity but
actually the state of the art of object
detection today is not only bounding
boxes it's now called image
understanding
so actually what what the state the what
a lot of people are trying to do today
is for each object not only give the
bounding box around the object but also
give what we call instance segmentation
which means we use we we do segmentation
we for each pixel we say if it's a
person or a table or whatever it is but
we are also aware of the separation
between the different people in the
image and there are even other things
you can do such as with very similar
frameworks almost with no additions such
as human key points estimation to
understand where the joints of humans
are from the from the images and in a in
a face book a eye a lecture I also saw
that they also take an image of a person
reading a book and are able to
understand what is the action the person
is doing and what object it is he is
doing it on so there are a lot of
creative things that you can do and I
actually put a list of resources here
and I'll put a link to this to these
these slides online in the meetup page
and these are just the basic papers that
are recommended to look at if you're
starting to work on in this field and
these are the more advanced resources
and this is a very good lecture by maybe
two of the really top experts in the
world of object detection both of them
work today in facebook AI and they show
many examples of how to exactly
implement the more creative ideas but
basically for example if you want to do
human pose estimation you just plug or
instant segmentation you just
in another head on top of the network so
this is it's very simple
between specifically yellow and SSD so I
didn't I actually don't know I don't I
didn't read anything any really thorough
comparison between them because the only
real comparison between them are in
maybe the yellow paper and the SSD paper
so it's very easy as I said to conduct
misleading comparisons because there are
many working points you can choose so I
can't really say that but both SSD and
viola are very similar and they both
they both use components that the
components that Yolo uses can be also
used in SSD so you should look at it as
the same thing and just try to take the
best of both worlds and it is not really
different algorithms if you work if you
want to implement a new algorithm don't
take Yolo ASIS or SSD as is try to look
at what they did in the SSD paper what
they did in the yellow paper and create
something new okay thank you very much